[Musik]
Donnerstagabend Sie sind im zweiten
deutschen Fernsehen und das ist gut so
jetzt ist es also soweit die Babyboomer
gehen in Rente nur wer macht künftig
ihre Arbeit schon hängen in fast jedem
Schaufenster Schilder Mitarbeiter
gesucht hunderttausende Fachkräfte
fehlen aber auch Bewerber für einfache
Jobs müssen die alten also länger ran
muss man den Jungen ihre
teilzeitpflausen austreiben rettet uns
allein die Zuwanderung und warum wirkt
die Politik so überrumpelt von dieser
neuen
arbeiterlosigkeit wir müssen reden mit
diesen Gästen
Andrea Nahles Vorstandsvorsitzende der
Bundesagentur für Arbeit
die Grünen Vorsitzende Ricarda lang
Carsten Linnemann stellvertretender
CDU-Vorsitzender
der handwerkspräsident Jörg Dittrich
Elisabeth Mia von der Hertie-Stiftung
und die Autorin Sarah Weber sie sind zu
Gast bei Maybrit
Illner und die begrüßt alle Gäste dieser
Sendung ausgesprochen herzlich das
deutsche wohlstandsmodell wackelt weil
hier ist das Problem
auf dem Land wie in der Großstadt der
Missstand kaum überseebar immer mehr
Betriebe in Not Deutschland gehen die
Arbeitskräfte aus wenn jetzt die
Babyboomer in Rente gehen werden wir im
deutschen Arbeitsmarkt bis 2035 um 7
Millionen Personen schrumpfen unser
Wohlstand steht auf dem Spiel hunderte
Milliarden weniger Wirtschaftsleistung
prophezeien Experten allein durch
Personalmangel hinzu kommt Inflation und
Energiekrise doch der Herr über die
Wirtschaftsdaten gibt erstmal Entwarnung
bald schon zeigt die Konjunkturkurve
wieder nach oben es stagniert im Grunde
und dann steigt es Dank für das nächste
Jahr der Wirtschaftsminister rechnet
erstmal kurzfristig aber das Problem ist
nachhaltig schon jetzt fehlen eine halbe
Million Fachkräfte wir brauchen alle
helfenden Hände und klugen Köpfe in
Deutschland damit wir unseren Wohlstand
sichern können woher also kommen die
Arbeitskräfte für Deutschlands Zukunft
wo ältere oft zu früh in Rente gehen
die jungen mehrwerter Freizeit legen und
zugewanderte an der deutschen Bürokratie
verzweifeln
Andrea Nahles ist bei uns sie waren
Arbeitsministerin Frau Nahles und sind
jetzt seit einem halben Jahr die Chefin
der Bundesagentur für Arbeit
lange hatten wir Angst dass uns die
Arbeit ausgehen würde wegen der
Digitalisierung und jetzt suchen wir
Arbeitskräfte und zwar händeringend zwei
Millionen offene Stellen wie kommt das
naja also das ist eine Problematik die
ich schon lange sich angedeutet hat die
demografische Entwicklung ist nicht neu
es ist ein bisschen verzögert worden
weil dann doch durch auch
Fluchtbewegungen mehr Leute ins Land
gekommen sind aber es muss ganz klar
sagen das wird die größte
Herausforderung der nächsten Dekade auf
dem deutschen Arbeitsmarkt für die
deutsche Wirtschaft und deswegen müssen
auch alle mit anpacken um das Problem zu
lösen da werden wir auch viele gucken
müssen die Frauen die
älteren diejenigen die jetzt auch
Ausbildung suchen und nicht zuletzt
natürlich auch
Zuwanderung in Deutschland Arbeitsmarkt
reden müssen
Millionen offene Stellen die KfW rechnet
vor dass jedes zweite Unternehmen in
Deutschland bereits in seiner
Geschäftstätigkeit
eingeschränkt ist und dass das Fundament
für weiteres Wachstum bröckelt sehen Sie
das genauso in dieser Dimension wir
haben einen quartanten Fachkräftemangel
aber der ist in einigen Branchen
besonders stark das ist bei der Pflege
das ist im Handwerk das ist am Bau wir
haben bei den
Arbeitskräftemangel ist das nicht
flächendeckend in der Form ausgestaltet
bisher aber auch da deutet sich an dass
es in einigen Branchen engen wird und
insoweit denke ich muss jetzt wirklich
klar sein dass wir alle es mobilisieren
müssen und aus dem einfachen Grund auch
dass ich persönlich glaube dass wir
einfach viele Kraft brauchen um die
Transformation die ja parallel läuft
also wir haben ja nicht nur ein
Fachkräftemangel sondern große Aufgaben
da soll die Elektromobilität kommen in
den Diesel ablösen da haben wir eine
ganze Reihe von energetischen
Herausforderungen die müssen sie auch
gemacht werden dafür brauchen wir auch
Leute also Klimawandel macht sich auch
nicht von selbst also von daher ist das
aus meiner Sicht eben schön alles
zusammen in großes Thema ja der
Wirtschaftsminister Vize Kanzler dieses
Landes und Wirtschaftsminister sagt
überall fehlt es hören wir ihm
vielleicht auch noch mal zu
überall fehlt es und zwar bei
Ingenieuren bei Wissenschaftlerinnen und
Wissenschaftlern bei Handwerkerinnen bei
Handwerkern wir haben jetzt zwei
Millionen offene Stellen und wir werden
älter werden das ist biologisch nicht zu
verhindern die Babyboomer gehen in Rente
es ist ein richtiges Problem das auf uns
zukommt
sagt der Vizekanzler Elisabeth nieder
ist bei uns lange
Wirtschaftsjournalistin und heute bei
der hertiestiftung von mir das ist so
verrückt wir haben die Bundesregierung
gerade erklären lassen und gehört mit
dem Satz er sie sehr aktuell keinen
umfassenden Fachkräftemangel auf eine
kleine Frage
parlamentarische Anfrage der Linken und
parallel dazu gibt es einen Vizekanzler
und verschiedenste Institutionen die
sagen das ist richtig groß was stimmt
also es besteht die Gefahr dass es eine
Wachstumsbremse wird das ist total ernst
zu nehmen und ob man das nun mehr oder
weniger umfassend finde ich dann gar
nicht so wichtig ich glaube dass da
geht's da geht's Worte aber das Problem
ist da das ist auch schon lange da ich
glaube wir haben es lange nicht so
gesehen weil es ein paar Sondereffekt in
Deutschland gab es zum Beispiel
unheimlich viele Frauen gerade so meiner
Generation
berufstätig sind Vollzeitstellen in
meiner Kindheit war der deutsche
Arbeitsmarkt gepr von männlichen
Vollzeitbeschäftigten und vielen Frauen
die wenn überhaupt nur Teilzeit
gearbeitet haben damals waren nicht mehr
die Hälfte aller Frauen überhaupt
berufstätig und wenn dann in Teilzeit
heute sind 71 Prozent und gerade von den
Eltern aber dieser Nachholeffekt ist
irgendwann verbraucht also wir können
diese Erwerbstätigkeit der Frauen nicht
ohne weiteres steigern das erklärt aber
auch so ein bisschen warum so viele in
Ruhestand gehen weil es lässt sich
einfach auch mit zwei Einkommen dann
leichter irgendwann der Ruhestand planen
die einzelnen Renten sind nicht
unbedingt höher aber das
Familieneinkommen ist höher als früher
als ein Paar oder eine Familie von einer
anderen
ist jetzt die Demografie das andere ist
noch mal die Frage warum sind
ausgerechnet in dieser Pandemie oder mit
der Pandemie oder nach ihr so viele
Arbeitskräfte verloren gegangen woanders
hin
na gut es haben natürlich teilweise auch
Unternehmen einfach sind sind pleite
gegangen oder vom Markt verschwunden in
der Gastronomie zum Beispiel es ist aber
auch tatsächlich einfach jetzt so ein
Strukturwandel da meinetwegen in meiner
alten Branche im Journalismus gehen
viele dann irgendwie immer noch so mit
vorruhestandsmodellen sehr sehr gut
ausgebildete teurere Arbeitskräfte und
das sind eben nicht diejenigen die
gesucht werden die jetzt irgendwie bei
einem Kurierdienst anfangen würden und
in diesem ganzen Dienstleistungsbereich
der sehr sehr explodiert ist und auch
diejenigen die jetzt sozusagen neue
digitale digitalarbeitsplätze irgendwie
nutzen Sie nicht unbedingt diejenigen
die die Ausscheiden also es gibt einfach
so ein Ungleichgewicht und alles
versucht das so mit
Weiterbildungsaktivitäten voran zu
schieben aber das ist natürlich ein
mühsames Geschäft bis das so auf jeden
Fall passt und deswegen erleben wir dass
wir gleichzeitig offene Stellen haben
und Arbeitslose wir sind mit ihr
Dietrich heute glücklich in diese Runde
bestückt er ist gerade der Handwerks
Präsident geworden und keine zuständig
für eine Million Betriebe deutsche
sandwerk und 686 Milliarden Umsatz
jährlich sie sind gelernter Dachdecker
Herr Dittrich wie lange muss man heute
warten wenn man sich von ihnen das
Dachdecken lassen möchte
ungefähr ein Vierteljahr muss man warten
wir kommen aus einer Situation in der
Handwerksleistung quasi am nächsten Tag
verfügbar war ich finde es nicht so
schlimm dass man jetzt mal 12 oder
Wochen auf einen Handwerker warten muss
notfälle werden natürlich eher
bearbeitet aber die Wartezeiten werden
sich erweitern wenn wir das Problem der
Fachkräfte nicht in den Griff bekommen
und würde es auch teurer
natürlich wird es teurer wir haben ganz
viele kostenschübe Energie Material
vollkommen klar aber in dem Augenblick
wo Fachkräfte weniger werden wird
natürlich der Wettbewerb auch über den
Lohn stärker werden und das ist für die
Leute die dort arbeiten auch gut so das
ist für ihre Mitarbeiter gut so und das
haben sie auch verdient auch darüber
werden wir reden uns ist in Bremen
zugeschaltet eine der zwei Vorsitzenden
von Bündnis 90 die Grünen Frau lang
einen guten Abend zu ihnen ähm wie
würden sie das Problem beschreiben zwei
Millionen oder aktuell keinen wirklichen
umfassenden Fachkräftemangel was sagt
Rebecca lang
wir haben auf jeden Fall ein
Fachkräftemangel ich glaube das ist
offensichtlich und ich würde sogar noch
weitergehen an vielen Stellen haben wir
auch ein Arbeitskräftemangel und ich bin
der Überzeugung dass die Demo der
demografische Wandel der Umgang mit
einer alternden Gesellschaft eigentlich
die vergessene Krise und zur Zeit ist
und eine der größten Herausforderungen
verbunden mit der Transformation für die
nächsten 10 Jahre würden Sie uns
erklären können warum die Politik so
überrascht ist würden sie auch sagen man
hätte sich das mit dem Rechenschieber
eigentlich denken können
naja ich glaube ich kann wenig für die
letzten 16 Jahre sprechen denn da war
weder ich Teil der Regierung noch meine
Partei aber natürlich hätte man vieles
sehen können vieles war ja
offensichtlich dass wir in einer
alternden Gesellschaft leben dass die
Babyboomer irgendwann in Rente gehen
auch das war ja nichts was ich plötzlich
ergeben hat und dass wir bei der
Einwanderung den Fehler gemacht haben
dass oft eher zu erdulden als aktiv zu
gestalten
wir ein großes politische für Säumnis
jetzt geht's darum sehr schnell das
erwerbspotenzial zu heben also dafür zu
sorgen dass mehr Frauen in Vollzeit
arbeiten können dass wir auf
einwanderungssätzen und natürlich auch
die Löhne so gut sind dass die Leute
dafür arbeiten wollen würden Sie sagen
Frau Nahles das ist tatsächlich auch ein
Problem ist dass so wenig in den Zeiten
der großen Koalitionen geschehen ist am
Arbeitsmarkt also muss müssen die Grünen
da jetzt auch wegräumen was
beispielsweise in ihrer Zeit als
Arbeitsministerin liegen geblieben ist
also ich kann nur sagen es ist eine
riesen Leistung erbracht worden wir
haben eine riesen Flüchtlingswelle
gehabt und
überdurchschnittlich gut die Menschen in
den Arbeitsmarkt integriert und damit
sicherlich eine große Leistung
vollbracht es ist aber auch richtig das
würde ich ganz klar sagen dass wir was
die Zuwanderung angeht nicht entschieden
genug vorgegangen sind und das System
was wir derzeit haben ist einfach so
kompliziert dass wenn wir es nicht
einfacher machen dann wird es
tatsächlich am Ende auch wirklich nicht
die nötige schubwirkung entfalten die
wir in Deutschland brauchen auch so
bleiben wir reden über Zuwanderung auf
jeden Fall noch Kassen Linnemann ist bei
uns man muss im Grunde ja auch sagen
auch sie waren sehr lange an der
Regierung diese Zustand jetzt kann ihnen
auch keine Freude bereiten es gibt
Ökonomen es gibt Wissenschaftler die
sagen die Menschen die da gerade am
Arbeitsmarkt fehlen die haben sich jetzt
einfach bessere Berufe gesucht die sind
eben nicht mehr irgendwie in der
Gastronomie und schuften in furchtbar
anstrengenden Jobs sondern
die haben sich jetzt besser bezahlte
Jobs gesucht ist das möglich in ihren
Augen unter anderem von hier hat ja
einige Gründe genannt aber es gibt zwei
weitere Gründe erstens haben viele die
Gastronomie des Hotelwesen verlassen es
gab Corona es gab ein Lockdown man
wollte Weg in die Logistik
beispielsweise wo es eine enorme
Nachfrage gibt und auf der anderen Seite
gibt es viele die einfach fertig waren
nach dieser Zeit in der Pflege und den
anderen Bereichen die gesagt haben ich
wende mich jetzt anderen
Herausforderungen zu trotzdem macht es
das nicht besser ich finde irgendwann
wird es Zeit dass die Politik sich auch
mal ehrlich macht und sagt diese Lücke
wir reden ja über sieben Millionen
Menschen die bis 2035 fehlen werden wir
so nicht schließen können wir müssen
alles tun gerade inländisch werden
50.000 Kinder immer noch die die Schule
ohne Schulabschluss verlassen wir haben
600.000 Menschen zwischen 14 und 24 die
wieder eine Ausbildung haben noch am
Arbeitsmarkt sind wir haben 2,5
Millionen Arbeitslose das müssen wir
alles machen
3 Millionen gar nicht richtig aber meine
Prognose ist und da mache ich mich
wahrscheinlich jetzt in dieser Runde
unbeliebt aber müssen uns darauf
einstellen dass wir 20 25 Prozent
weniger Fachkräfte auch im Mittelstand
im Handwerk auch im Gesundheitswesen
haben werden das werden wir auch durch
Zuwanderung nicht schaffen und deshalb
müssen wir auch die Systeme so
einstellen dass wir effizienter werden
dass wir besser werden und gleichzeitig
das inländische inländische Potenzial
dass wir Millionen Menschen in
Deutschland haben wo wir es nicht
schaffen die zum Arbeiten zu bekommen
besser werden das ist also diese wäre
die nächste Frage von Hannes haben wir
Stichwort stille Reserve das sind
Menschen die aus verschiedensten Gründen
nicht in den Arbeitsmarkt können oder
ins Arbeitsleben können zwischen 17 und
70 aber gerne arbeiten würden sind die
einfach zu teuer zu aufwendig dass wir
da als Staat schon die Waffen gestreckt
haben und gesagt haben das nee nein die
Langzeitarbeitslosigkeit ist jetzt
gerade im letzten Monat haben wir das
zeigen können wieder um 10% gesunken es
tut etwas auf dem Arbeitsmarkt wir haben
aber das Problem dass zwei Drittel der
Langzeitarbeitslosen über 55 sind oder
von der Qualifizierung auf helfer-niveau
die Stellen die aber gesucht werden wenn
wir die den Arbeitgebern schicken würden
dann sagen die moment mal so können wir
das nicht schaffen wir brauchen da
zwischen einfach tatsächlich auch
Qualifizierung wir müssen die Leute
teilweise wenn sie jahrelang aus dem
Rhythmus sind wenn sie da jahrelang
arbeitslos waren dann müssen wir die
teilweise sogar an die Hand nehmen und
Coaching machen und sagen jetzt sorgen
wir und da muss ich dann der Arbeitgeber
nicht drum kümmern dafür dass sie auch
morgens da sind das werden wir angehen
dafür haben wir auch Instrumentenkasten
jetzt gerade bei den
Langzeitarbeitslosen durch das
Bürgergeld noch mal erweitert aber ich
sage die Tatsache ist das ist momentan
nicht nett der Arbeitsplatz der offene
und die Arbeitslosen die wir haben das
müssen wir zusammenführen und das wird
nicht ohne eine Qualifizierungsoffensive
gehen das ist eine große Aufgabe von mir
müssen eben erst recht und genau deshalb
weil das ja auch nicht so schnell zu
machen sein wird die alten wiederin
na das wird über den Markt geregelt das
wird eine Preisfrage sein also die
Unternehmen haben sich glaube ich in den
letzten Jahren generell geöffnet für
ältere Leute also diese
Altersdiskriminierung ist nicht mehr so
ein Thema aber wenn man zum Beispiel in
der Pflege ältere gewinnmühle muss man
unter Umständen auch höhere Löhne zahlen
also das ist gerade Pflegeberufe sind
lange schlecht bezahlt worden also noch
nicht so lange her dass Leute die
Ausbildung gemacht haben sogar Schulgeld
dafür bezahlen mussten wenn sie in die
Pflege wollten bis 20 erst 2020 ist das
abgeschafft worden man fasst sich
wirklich am Kopf wie das möglich ist da
der Föderalismus versagt viel zu viel
Abstimmungsprobleme und das ändert sich
halt wirklich erst sehr sehr langsam und
insofern ich glaube schon also die Fazit
hat gerade geschrieben Rente kommt
wieder in Mode ich glaube das wird man
durch besser bezahlte Jobs ändern müssen
in dem Bereich ist aber auch durch
andere Jobs also sind stiftende Jobs
Jobs mit einem guten Arbeitsklima mit
flexiblen mobilen Arbeitsplätzen und so
weiter es kann gerade dieses Thema also
sind beschäftigen wir uns auch Stiftung
fiel damit Unternehmen die was für die
Demokratie tun wollen und so weiter da
gibt es auch großes Interesse in der
Wirtschaft sich zu verändern und ich
glaube da gibt es so ein gemeinsamen
Lernprozess gerade und da ein Angebot zu
machen eine idee-studie wurde gerade
gemacht Institut für Wirtschaft sie sagt
es ist dreimal so wichtig diese älteren
zu gewinnen und vom grauen Gold wird
gesprochen und auch Olaf Scholz möchte
den Trend der
Frühverrentung stoppen der Bundeskanzler
sagte
es gilt den Anteil derer zu steigern die
wirklich bis zum Renteneintrittsalter
arbeiten können
so da wünscht sich der Bundeskanzler das
weniger Menschen vor Erreichen
des Rentenalters aufhören
ärgert es Sie Frau Nahles manchmal dass
sie als Arbeit ärgert ist die
Arbeitsvermittlerin Nahles dass sie
damals als Arbeitsministerin die Rente
mit 63 mit initiiert haben und möglich
gemacht haben wir haben damals eine
Würdigung einer Leistung gebracht von
Jahrgängen von einer Generation die mit
15 16 in die Ausbildung gegangen ist
dann 45 Jahre gearbeitet hat und da
wollten wir einfach dass die nicht
dadurch bestraft werden dass sie
Abschläge hinnehmen müssen dazu stehe
ich trotzdem wir diese Rente die ohnehin
nur einen kleinen Teil der Gesamtgruppe
der Rentner betroffen hat und die ja
jetzt auch immer weniger werden trotzdem
ist die Erwerbsbeteiligung von älteren
seit 2015 gestiegen und zwar deutlich
wir hatten 2015 36 Prozent der 60
65-Jährigen die gearbeitet haben wir
haben jetzt 50 Prozent da kann man
natürlich weiter überlegen was was
müssen wir denn tun damit ältere
Menschen weiter arbeiten können und
wollen und da glaube ich ist ein Faktor
wirklich die Arbeitszeit weil viele
sagen ich kann den Tag voll nicht mehr
mitgehen aber reduziert ja wir sehen es
daran dass eine Million Menschen
Teilzeit arbeiten nachdem sie in
Ruhestand gegangen sind wir haben jetzt
vom IAB unserem Forschungsinstitut
gefragt warum man könnte ja vermuten
wegen Geld nein die Mehrzahl der Leute
sagt weil sie eine sinnvolle Aufgabe
haben weil sie noch Wissen weitergeben
wollen weil sie ihn noch Spaß macht und
da glaube ich müssen wir ansetzen wenn
wir auf dieses Potenzial jetzt gucken
und da kann man auch noch einiges machen
das ist hoch interessant Frau lang muss
die Rente mit 63 wieder weg können wir
sie uns noch leisten
nein aus meiner Sicht nicht also nicht
dass sie weg muss es sondern ich glaube
wir müssen das ja anschauen auf der
einen Seite sollte es unser Ziel sein
dass mehr Menschen die länger arbeiten
wollen und können das so einfach wie
möglich so unbürokratisch wie möglich
tun können und gleichzeitig muss man
sagen dass eine pauschale rentnerhöhung
gerade für die Menschen die das nicht
können ich denke da an den Handwerker
der vielleicht schon physische Probleme
hat ich denke die Pflegekraft die das
körperlich einfach nicht mehr schafft
für die würde eine pauschale Erhöhung
des Rentenalters nichts anderes bedeuten
als eine Rentenkürzung und das finde ich
extrem ungerecht und es würde sogar dazu
führen dass diese Berufe in denen wir
einen der größten Fachkräftemangel haben
am Ende noch unattraktiver werden gerade
da wo wir die Menschen anwerben müssen
und am Ende müssen wir glaube ich auch
sehen dass die Schlacht um die Rente
ganz ganz stark vor allem am
Arbeitsmarkt entschieden wird also
anhand der Frage wie gut sind die Löhne
und wie viele Leute zahlen ein sagt
Ricarda langjährig manche Berufe kann
man nicht bis 67 machen gerade von der
SPD wurde die berühmte Dachdecker ja
immer benannt und hoch gehalten als
einer der eben nicht über 45 Jahre und
dann bis 67 auf dem Dach stehen kann wie
lange werden sie noch aufs Dach klettern
oder klettert der Chef nicht mehr ich
bin arbeite nicht auf dem Dach ich gehe
da zur Kontrolle hin aber natürlich weiß
ich als Chef eines solchen Betriebes wie
es ist mit einer körperlich
beanspruchenden Arbeit und es ist für
mich natürlich schwierig wenn immer der
Dachdecker herangezogen wird und es
viele andere Berufe gibt bei denen es
vielleicht nicht so ist aber wir müssen
ja zuerst mal die Aufmerksamkeit der
Gesellschaft erzeugen dass es eine
Zeitenwende auch hier gibt was die
Fachkräfte angeht das ist einen
eklatantenmangel gibt einfach Kräften
und das die Betriebe die
Handwerksbetriebe Gründe finden müssen
wie sie ältere Beschäftigte länger
halten können indem sie Arbeit
erleichtern in den attraktiv ist das
gibt auch im Dachdeckerhandwerk Dinge
ist da ein älterer der sich um die
Ausbildung mehr kümmert die
Kundenbetreuung
mitmacht oder mit der Drohne mit in
Ihrer Firma beispielsweise versuchen Sie
ältere Menschen länger zu halten
natürlich versuchen wir das aber es muss
ja wie gesagt von allen Seiten
betrachtet werden und deswegen Frau
Nahles die
abschlagsfreien Rente gehen mit mit
einem Abschlag in Rente gehen und dann
eine zuverdienstmöglichkeit dass es im
Sinne der Gesellschaft schwierig wir
müssen es schaffen möglichst viele
Menschen bis zum regulären
Renteneintritt zu haben und dann
gesellschaftlich auch den Anreiz zu
setzen dass Leute länger bleiben die
dann etwas dazu verdienen und ich kann
das bestätigen wir haben auch so ein
Mitarbeiter der schon jetzt das
Rentenalter erreicht hat der im Winter
sagt ach da bin ich mal acht Wochen zu
Hause Meister und danach komme ich dann
wieder zu meiner Kolonne zurück und mach
damit das ist toll Herr Lindemann ist
sowieso für die Rente mit 70 wir wollen
doch nicht um das klar zu stellen in
meinem Urteil war die Rente mit 63 eines
der größten sozialpolitischen Fehler der
großen Koalition
kann sie aber auch zugestimmt Helene
Schmerzen vermutet genau damals habe ich
ja zum Glück die flexi-rente noch
durchsetzen können damit die Menschen
Anreiz haben auch länger zu arbeiten die
dies wollen es waren Kompromiss
jemand der in Deutschland Vollender 45
Jahre gearbeitet hat der muss eine Rente
bekommen von der erleben kann aber diese
Rente mit 63 war für die Dachdecker und
Maurer für die Pfleger die körperliche
hart arbeiten 90% der Kollegen von
handytrich sind mit 60 Jahren nicht mehr
auf dem Dach und die hat man im Stich
gelassen stattdessen hat man zu großen
Teilen top fette Leute aus dem
Arbeitsmarkt rausgezogen die jetzt
fehlen und das war meines Erachtens ein
Fehler stattdessen hätte man die mehr
unterstützen müssen die körperlich
kaputt waren die sind leer ausgegangen
beispielsweise bei dir erwerbsgeminder
gemacht natürlich ich war mit in der
Verantwortung das war damals
da geht wir waren glaube ich auch bei
Ihnen hier zusammen in der Sendung aber
jetzt mal nach vorne gerichtet aber
jetzt mal was nach vorne gerichtet mein
Vorschlag wäre eine neue Rente eine neue
aktivrente ich würde wenn jetzt diese
Babyboomer kommen die sie toll
exemplarisch gerade dargestellt haben
bis zu 1,3 Millionen Menschen die in den
Anfang der 60er Jahren geboren wurden
die jetzt in Rente gehen ich würde für
alle die das gesetzliche
Renteneintrittsalter erreichen und dann
freiwillig länger arbeiten das
steuerfrei machen
Sozialversicherungsbeiträge müssen
natürlich bezahlt werden klar auch für
die Krankenkasse aber ich würde
steuerfrei machen wir haben
außergewöhnliche Zeiten sind wirklich
außergewöhnliche Zeiten neben der
Inflation und neben unseres
Wirtschaftsstandorts und
Industriestandorts ist dieses Thema
Fachkräfte das entscheidende Thema und
jetzt brauchen wir außergewöhnliche
Instrumente und für mich wäre das alle
Menschen die im gesetzlichen Rentenalter
sind die freiwillig weiterarbeiten
dürfen das tun steuerfrei das wäre mein
Vorschlag und da was gegen zu machen für
die Menschen die
Rente gegangen sind mit Rente mit 63 ist
das sicher gut gewesen ich möchte nicht
gegen diese Menschen sprechen aber ich
möchte auch betonen das können wir uns
nicht mehr leisten auch vor dem
Hintergrund der
Generationengerechtigkeit wir müssen das
ja alles finanzieren und ich wiederhole
noch einmal auch mit Blick auf die
eigene Branche dass wir versuchen müssen
Gründe zu finden wie wir Menschen länger
am Arbeit halten und dann ist es genau
diese Verbindung wie können wir es
überhaupt gestalten Alterns gerechtes
Arbeiten wird es ja von den
Gewerkschaften genannt dass man nicht
kaputt ist mit 60 ja es ist so bisher
gewesen das müssen wir irgendwie besser
in den Griff bekommen und wie können wir
es Anreizen dass diese Menschen länger
arbeiten wenn man das umsetzt dass jeder
der noch kann und definitiv steuerfrei
weiterarbeiten
man darf nicht vergessen es hat einen
finanziellen Aspekt und ist es denn
wirklich so dass jeder sich diese Rente
leisten kann zu sagen mit dem Wasser hat
dass er vielleicht auch froh ist etwas
dazu zu verdienen und was ich noch viel
wichtiger sagen möchte der Kollege von
dem ich sprach für ihn geht es um die
soziale Anbindung der ist gern mit
seinen Kollegen zusammen und ja er kann
nicht den ganzen Tag die aller schwerste
Arbeit machen aber ist
es noch nicht wenn wir die Menschen
länger im Arbeitsprozess halten wollen
und sie dann aber jetzt in der Rente
dann lieber noch steuerfrei etwas dazu
verdienen lassen wollen das widerspricht
sich ja eigentlich also wenn man
steuerfrei etwas dazu verdienen kann ist
man ja noch viel schneller überzeugt
früher in Rente gehen
gesetzlichen Rentenalter im Moment sind
es reguläre und 10 Monate wir gehen ja
jetzt auf die 67 zu wer das gesetzliche
Rentenalter erreicht ab dem Zeitpunkt
und freiwillig länger arbeiten ist mein
Vorschlag steuerfrei was ist denn wir
haben sie es genannt aktiv sind
ja auch nicht so richtig schön neue die
neue illnerin
Rente natürlich werden hätte durch die
Frage ist eben sie haben das erwähnt und
diesen einen Mitarbeiter erwähnt
Unternehmer freuen sich immer über eine
längere Rente und bis 67 arbeiten oder
bis 69 arbeiten aber fassen dann auch
schon mal gerne in Arbeitnehmer mit
spitzen Fingern an der dann erst 50 ist
also auch in der Unternehmerschaft wenn
ich das mal ganz freundlich sagen darf
muss ja da noch Überzeugungsarbeit
geleistet werden oder ich habe das
Empfinden dass dieser Umdenkprozess
schon fast abgeschlossen ist weil es
diese Fachkräfte Mangel schon gibt es
gibt einen eklatanten Fachkräftemangel
auch im Handwerk und deswegen öffnen
sich Betrieben natürlich auch dafür es
ist ein Unterschied wir es ist ja nicht
so dass wir seit 30 Jahren in der
Vollbeschäftigung leben werden eine
Agenda 2010 um Arbeitslosigkeit zu
bekämpfen und dieses Denken war sicher
drin aber wir sitzen ja heute hier um
deutlich zu machen es brechen andere
Zeiten an die Frau Finale sie haben es
gemerkt die Rente mit 63 ist hier am
Tisch nicht so wohl gelitten auch in
Bremen nicht würden Sie sagen wir können
es also sagen sie auch heute können wir
es uns eigentlich nicht mehr leisten den
Menschen sei es gegönnt aber wir könnten
hat 45 Beitragsjahre wer von denen ist
mit 15 16 überhaupt in die Arbeit
reingekommen das Problem ist doch das
gerne verstehen dass man jetzt versucht
das auf diese Frage zuzuspitzen dafür
eignet sich die Rente 63
auch gerechnet haben also es kostet auch
was entschuldigung es werden immer
weniger es ist nicht das Problem was
jetzt im quer im Stall steht um die
Frage der
älteren
arbeitsbeteiligung zu lösen wir haben an
dieser Stelle eine Debatte gehabt was
eine bestimmte Zahl von Jahrgängen
betraf
diejenigen die jetzt 64 die Babyboomer
erreichen gar nicht mehr die 45
das ist eine Entschuldigung an der
Stelle wird das Problem jetzt an der
Stelle hier größer gemacht als es ist
ich werbe dafür und das finde ich
wichtig dass wir über die Arbeitszeit
und über die Belastung nachdenken wir
haben einen Anstieg der älteren die ihm
Erwerbsleben sind das ist ein positiver
Trend wie kriegen wir den verstärkt weil
kriegen wieder andere rein darüber
sollten wir uns unterhalten damit es am
Ende auch funktioniert aus meiner
die Frage wie sie heute darauf gucken es
konnten sowieso nur alle die vor 1953
geboren sind ohne Abschläge diese 45
Jahre aber und das gestatten sie es sind
eben mehr geworden als sie das geschätzt
haben das ist auch ein ordentlicher
Posten der das Land einfach etwas kostet
so und insofern darf man fragen und die
Kollegen aus der Politik werden das wenn
das jetzt mitnehmen und gestalten wie
wie wie gespannt
die Generation meiner Tochter Leid und
wenn ich das höre hätte man so
Steuergeschenke dann noch mal für die
älteren die länger arbeiten vielleicht
ist das eine Notlösung weil es nicht
anders geht
die arbeiten ja jetzt nicht das ist
keine das ist überhaupt nicht der stark
profitiert neue Kaufkraft Wachstum
Wertschöpfung die Frage ist wie sie ihre
Prioritäten setzen und wir haben einfach
eine junge Generation auch die von Frau
lang die die ganz viel gleichzeitig
finanzieren müssen die müssen die
Transformation bewerkstelligen die
sollen sowieso für einen riesige Zahl
von Rennen
bezahlen die soll digitalisieren sollen
wahrscheinlich auch eine
ältere länger arbeiten das würde doch
eher Argument unterstützen ja aber mir
fehlt wirklich die Bereitschaft auch in
Bildung und zu investieren genau und was
zu tun also wir reden so lange auch über
Schulabbrecher die Zahl ist über die
Jahre sogar noch weiter gestiegen und
ich glaube das ist halt so ein Prozess
der sich in der alternden Gesellschaft
selber verstärkt dass irgendwie mehr
ältere wählen und reden und so weiter
immer weniger in die Bildung von
jüngeren investiert wird
es gibt einen interessanten neuen Trend
jenseits dieser eben sich leider
verfestigt haben dann Befunde das ist
auch immer noch viel zu viele
Schulabbrecher gibt die alten hauen rein
es hauen auch ein Großteil der
fortisings rein aber es gibt junge
Menschen die für sich entschieden haben
dass sie nicht mehr ganz so viel
arbeiten wollen wie es ihnen ihre Eltern
vorgemacht haben und das gucken wir uns
mal an
ein junger US-Amerikaner spricht über
seine Arbeitseinstellung und dabei
offenbar vielen aus dem Herzen
du machst eine Pflichten aber du machst
nicht mehr mit beim lebensbestimmenden
Job Stress
es geht um quiet quitting frei übersetzt
Dienst nach Vorschrift ein neuer Trend
der Generation Z
Jugendforscher bestätigen Veränderungen
die jungen Leute haben große Sorgen vor
einer Überforderung und fragen sich ob
sich Leistung überhaupt noch lohnt
für Unternehmen eine neue Lage einige
nutzen dieselbe Plattform im Kampf um
Fachkräfte tanzen für den Nachwuchs in
diesem deutschen Betrieb gehen seit dem
Video des Pressesprechers deutlich mehr
Bewerbungen ein
ja also da muss man doch gleich ein
Dietrich mal fragen haben Sie schon mal
den Nachwuchs angetanzt
an tanzen
nein ich habe das nicht aber auf den
sozialen Medien
natürlich unterwegs und bei uns auch
recht erfolgreich aber wichtig ist ja
wie sieht es im gesamten Handwerk aus
und da gibt es große Herausforderungen
weil die duale Berufsausbildung die
berufliche Bildung der universitäre
nicht gleichgestellt ist dort ist dann
ein ganz großer Punkt für mich dass wir
eine bildungswende schaffen müssen wir
brauchen
Berufsberatung Berufsorientierung an
allen Schulen auch an den Gymnasien weil
die Priorisierung die wir haben die ist
uns aus dem Boden gelaufen es gehen zu
viel in Richtung Studium die vielleicht
dann zu einem zu späten Zeitpunkt
erkennen dass sie dort gar nicht gut
aufgehoben sind wir müssen es schaffen
die Leute dorthin zu bekommen auch die
Talente ins goldene Handwerker
das wäre was SARAH Weber faszinierend
könnte ich möchte sie sehr sehr herzlich
begrüßen bei uns sie sind Autoren und
sind digital Expertin sie haben bis 19s
2021 gearbeitet bei LinkedIn als
redaktionelle Chefin und haben ein Buch
geschrieben im letzten Jahr mit einem
ganz schön traurigen Titel und der ist
frau Weber die Welt geht unter und ich
muss trotzdem arbeiten ja und Sie haben
gefunden dass das alles einfach zu viel
ist und dass sie unbedingt aus diesem
Arbeitsprozess heraus mussten was hat
sie an diese Arbeit so kaputt gemacht
also es war auch nicht der einzige Grund
aber ich habe gekündigt ein Jahr nach
Pandemie beginnen und wie bei vielen
anderen Menschen auch ich war einfach
erschöpft ich war müde und ich war auch
in der Situation dass ich sagen konnte
okay das ist jetzt für mich der Punkt wo
ich gehe und habe dann auch eine Pause
gemacht was ein unfassbares Privileg ist
dass ich sehr viele Menschen leider
nicht leisten können
und das ist gleich die nächste Frage ist
natürlich gibt sehr viele Menschen die
einfach harte Jobs haben und nicht in
ihren Traum Berufen arbeiten und die
keine Chance haben zu sagen ich mache
jetzt mal ein bisschen weniger haben sie
für ihr Buch auch mit denen Kontakt
gehabt und mit denen gesprochen ja auf
jeden Fall also auch mit mit dem
Handwerk ich habe zum Beispiel mit einem
Bäcker gesprochen ich habe aber generell
auch gesehen dass in ganz vielen
Bereichen ist Lösungen gibt wo Menschen
auch wirklich sich andere Arbeitsmodelle
schaffen oder auch wirklich für
Entlastung kämpfen also wo wirklich
nicht nur sagen alles ist schlecht
sondern sich auch überlegen wie könnte
es besser sein wir können Sie noch mal
sagen warum sie denken dass an dieser
Arbeit wie wir sie heute wie Sie sie in
eben der digitalbranche betrieben haben
der Mensch auch krank wird dass die
krank macht diese Arbeit warum ist das
so das ist gar keine branchensache also
wir sehen wirklich in Studien der Stress
bei den Menschen nimmt zu und er nimmt
erst wieder ab am Ende des Erwerbslebens
also die Menschen arbeiten und
wahnsinnig gestresst und sind dann erst
wenn nicht mehr gestresst wenn sie nicht
arbeiten müssen nicht im Studium Schule
Beruf sind und das ist ein unfassbares
Problem wir haben eben schon hier in
dieser Runde viel über physische
Gesundheit gesprochen aber noch nicht so
viel über die mentale Gesundheit und
dass das ein Punkt ist der bei vielen
Menschen einfach gerade nicht mehr so
funktioniert
was denken Sie wer wird die Windräder
bauen die wir brauchen wer wird die
Leuchttürme in die Landschaft setzen
Handwerk ist als Stichwort schon
gefallen ihre Lösung ist jetzt erstmal
zu sagen wir brauchen Ruhe und wir
müssen aussteigen und die Menschen
müssen erstmal wieder zu sich finden
oder sagen Sie dieses quiet quitting
dieses Dienst nach Vorschrift und mental
aussteigen und nicht mehr dabei sein ist
dann auch unsere Zukunft also ich glaube
dass wir generell systemische Lösungen
brauchen also dass das nicht jede Person
für sich individuell regeln kann sondern
dass wir wirklich schauen müssen vor
allem wenn wir wollen dass Leute
vielleicht sogar länger arbeiten wie
können wir denn dahin kommen dass die
Leute gut arbeiten und dann auch
wirklich in der Lage sind nicht
irgendwie mit 50 vollkommen ausgebrannt
sind oder mit 20 zum Teil schon also
wirklich auch jungen sagen sie packen
das nicht mehr sondern wie kommen wir
dahin dass Menschen auch wirklich gut
arbeiten können und sich auf ihr Leben
konzentrieren können und die Arbeit ist
ein Teil davon aber nicht der Hauptteil
und was haben sie für sich selber
herausgefunden wäre jetzt irgendwie aus
ihrer warte angemessen und okay also wie
viel wollen Sie überhaupt arbeiten ich
arbeite gerne aber ich merke zum
Beispiel auch dass so Tage diese
durchgetaktet sind wie Miete mit
Meetings kennen ja bestimmt auch viele
hier im Raum dass das zum Beispiel für
mich sehr schlecht war und ich konnte
das jetzt auch reduzieren und ich glaube
an solchen Punkten müssen wir ansetzen
oder eben auch den Berufen wo das
natürlich nicht der Fall ist ne gibt es
Sachen die reduziert werden können gibt
es Sachen wo uns auch die Technologie
die so viel besser geworden ist Dinge
abnehmen kann Sarah Weber ist heute bei
uns und sie sind so lieb und kommen mit
in die Hunde damit wir am allerbesten
gemeinsam diskutieren können Sinnsuche
Frau lang in Bremen muss unbedingt
gefragt werden nach dem was wir jetzt
zusammen mal zu den älteren und den
Jungen gehört haben also Rente bis 70
und dann brennen wir aber eigentlich mit
40 schon aus das kann ja auch nicht die
Zukunft sein in ihren Augen nie auf gar
keinen Fall zwei Punkte von mir
vielleicht ich würde einmal noch ganz
kurz auf Diedrich eingehen weil ich das
sehr sehr zustimmen würde ich habe
selbst mein Abschluss vor zehn Jahren
gemacht mein Schulabschluss und damals
immer das ist perfekt okay dann machen
wir das umgekehrt dann rede ich erstmal
das andere ich glaube das sind natürlich
fragen die sich viele junge Menschen
stellen und ehrlich gesagt manchmal wird
das ja gerne so ein bisschen abgetan als
Luxusprobleme oder sehr Platte Thesen
die jungen wollen alle nicht mehr
arbeiten was ja überhaupt nicht stimmt
ich glaube wir müssen zehn gerade im
hochqualifizierten Bereich ist es
heutzutage für Unternehmen auch eine
Notwendigkeit damit zu beschäftigen wie
werde ich Leute an viele Menschen haben
diese Möglichkeiten über die wir
gesprochen haben gerade gar nicht aber
in vielen Stellen geht vor auch um eins
und das ist Vereinbarkeit also wenn zum
Beispiel Menschen Kinder bekommen sich
Kindererziehung vielleicht auch
gleichberechtigte aufteilen wollen als
es in der Vergangenheit der Fall war
dann stellt sich sehr groß die Frage von
flexiblen Arbeitszeiten von einer
Verteilung von Arbeitszeiten es war
glaube ich es geht gar nicht darum
unbedingt dass alle weniger arbeiten
sondern es geht darum wie verteilen wir
Arbeit wie kommen wir von Weg das
teilweise Frauen immer noch eine
teilzeitfalle stecken und gleichzeitig
andere bis zum Burnout und weiter
darüber hinaus zu viel arbeiten das ist
ihre Stunde sie überzeugen jetzt bitte
Frau Weber das sie eine goldene Zukunft
hat
meine Erlebniswelt ist eine andere ich
möchte gerne mir eine positive Zukunft
vorstellen ich für mich ist immer
demografisches Problem ist nicht dass
die Menschen älter werden in
demografisches Problem haben haben wir
wenn wir uns keine positive Zukunft mehr
vorstellen können und das ist liegt mir
am Herzen ich würde sie dort gerne
mitnehmen in eine
positive Gedanken
sie haben natürlich Recht das ist
psychische Belastungen gibt und wir
haben sicher geklaut dass junge Menschen
die mit den sozialen Medien groß werden
schon gelernt haben den Umgang damit es
scheint doch was mit den Menschen zu
machen wenn man ständig nur negative
Nachrichten und 100 Mädels am Tag
bekommt und WhatsApp und was weiß ich
für für soziale Medien zusätzlich
bedient das scheint eine größere
psychische Belastung zu sein als wir uns
vorstellen in meiner Realität gibt es
Handwerksberufe die dieses materielle
anfassen von einem Gegenstand anders
darstellen und dann auch einen Sinn
einen Geist in einem Materie fließen
lassen
werden also sie müssen sich jetzt noch
nicht überzeugt haben lassen Frau Weber
aber die Frage auch in diesen
Alternativen zu denken und zu sagen
vielleicht probiere ich mich wirklich
auch in etwas ganz anderem aus
das ist ja jedem möglich das auf jeden
Fall aber die Frage ist ja auch wissen
die Rahmenbedingungen also haben gerade
das Brötchen backen angesprochen ich
habe für mein Buch mit dem Bäcker
gesprochen der hat gesagt ich habe keine
Lust nachts zu backen ich will nicht
irgendwie morgens um eins anfangen zu
arbeiten der hat mittlerweile eine
eigene Bäckerei fängt morgens um halb
sechs an was für mich noch früh ist aber
für ihn relativ spät macht um 7 Uhr auf
und dann gibt's einfach noch nicht alles
und der hat sich einfach ein anderes
Modell geschaffen und ich glaube das ist
auch ein ganz wichtiger Punkt wirklich
zu sagen was funktioniert was
funktioniert auch nicht wie sieht es in
verschiedenen Branchen aus und wie
können wir an Punkt kommen wo es diese
Flexibilität gibt die aber auch sich
wirklich um die Menschen dreht und nicht
darum wie
Flexibilität im Sinne von alle müssen
immer erreichbar sein weil da stimme ich
Ihnen zu das ist ein Problem aber das
ist doch nicht nur ein Problem der
jungen wenn es um ständige erreichen
hat ist ja die Sache eigentlich auch
noch von alles am Ende ist doch
entscheidend wie effizient jemand
arbeitet würden sie auch sagen dass
durch aus wieder auf der anderen Seite
also bei den Unternehmern die
Bereitschaft gar nicht so groß ist zu
sagen ich kann die Stunden vom Freitag
eigentlich auch auf die vier anderen
Tage verteilen und dann haben wir die
vier Tage Woche die so beschimpft wird
von der Unternehmerschaft also auch
wieder mal seitenverkehrt kann man sagen
die Flexibilität sollten dann ruhig auch
die Unternehmer haben ich glaube das
fängt jetzt an diese Debatte bei den
Unternehmen ich beobachte das wir machen
jetzt zum Beispiel in Bayern im Märzen
Workshop mit dem bayerischen
Gesundheitsminister Arbeitsbedingungen
in der Pflege
ist eine junge Frau begegnet hätten
vierjährigen Sohn in Mansfeld die hat
mir erzählt sie ist Altenpflegerin
Schichtwechsel ist um 6 Uhr die erste
Kita macht erst um 7 Uhr auf und
entscheidet es daran wann fange ich an
da geht uns eine Altenpflegerin verloren
nur weil die
tanzen um 6 Uhr Frage nicht geklärt hat
also ich glaube wenn wir da ansetzen und
wirklich auch mal reingucken würden an
die Unternehmer habe ich jetzt auch öf
noch mal den Appell gerichtet guck doch
mal fragt doch mal die teilzeitfrauen
bei euch im Betrieb die machen jetzt 20
Stunden was müssten wir als Arbeitgeber
tun damit ihr 30 Stunden arbeitet und
wenn wir da an der Stelle die Debatte
von beiden Seiten führen kommen wir
glaube ich an vielen Stellen ein Stück
weiter da bin ich fest von überzeugt
hättetrich heizungsmonteure sagen hat
mir ein Beispiel in der heute gestern 19
Uhr eine heizungsmonteurfirma die das
genauso gemacht haben die haben die
Stunden vom Freitag verteilt alle sind
happy und die Firma läuft also die
machen natürlich die fünf Tage sind
trotzdem besetzt zum einen würde ich mir
mehr Flexibilität Wünschen in den
gesetzlichen Rahmen die wir setzen was
da an Nachweispflichten auch in
Arbeitszeit Aufzeichnungen drin liegt
was in Großkonzernen vielleicht gut
möglich ist aber in einem
Handwerksbetrieb mit fünf Mitarbeitern
braucht man das dort hat man das
Vertrauen miteinander ich glaube dass
diese Flexibilität genau richtig jeder
Betrieb auch schauen muss aber es gibt
eben auch Punkte bei denen diese soziale
Leistung für den Kunden notwendig ist
wenn die Heizung kaputt ist dann wird er
nicht gerne hören wollen dass man gerade
eine vier Tage Woche hat und ich bringe
ein anderes Beispiel weil das Thema
Effizienz gerade kam es geht eben nicht
alles nach Produktivität wenn wir ganz
produktiv bei der
Bäckereifachverkäuferin sagen du musst
das schneller bestellen damit du
schneller verschwinden kannst und nicht
die nächsten bedienen kann das wird
nicht das Interesse des Kunden sein und
in der Beratung weil im Friseursalon ist
das auch nicht so und da hängt es dann
natürlich auch an der Entlohnung kann
ich mir das leisten ich frage immer
gerade die jungen Menschen die dann
sagen ich möchte vier Tage die Woche
arbeiten hätten denn deine Eltern ist
finanziell überhaupt sich leisten können
weniger zu arbeiten da kommt häufig die
Antwort nein das wäre nicht gegangen
wenn was heute übersetzten wir können
das teilweise uns leisten das sollten
uns auch freuen dran aber es schränkt
auch die Möglichkeit ein Menschen mehr
Geld zu geben weil an dem Faktor Arbeit
die Sozialsysteme so diese
Benachteiligung die wollen wir nicht
mehr hinlegen sofort zwei Fragen eine an
Herrn Linnemann erstmal die jungen
Menschen haben diese Freiheit einfach
weil es ein Arbeitskräftemangel gibt und
das ist Marktwirtschaft und diese
Freiheit weniger arbeiten zu wollen
nehmen Sie sich so ein schönes Beispiel
von Frau Weber weil sie werden eine
andere Verhandlungsmacht sozusagen haben
weil sie sich den Arbeitgeber aussuchen
und nicht mehr der Arbeitgeber sie das
heißt wenn sie zum Arbeitgeber gehen und
sagen ich möchte aber zwei Tage
Homeoffice haben dort wo es geht jetzt
nicht im Handwerk aber dort wo es geht
hat sie eine sehr sehr gute Position auf
der anderen Seite müssen wir nur
aufpassen dass Arbeit auch in
Deutschland weiter etwas wert ist also
in den letzten Jahrzehnten haben die
Menschen gearbeitet aus existenziellen
gründen um den Lebensunterhalt zu
erwirtschaften und heute ist es so
leicht den letzten Krisen hat sich der
Staat so weit ausgeweitet dass er so tut
als ob er für alles sorgt und für alles
verantwortlich ist in der coronakrise
oder auch jetzt in der Ukraine
Energiekrise
der verteilt so das Geld als ob alle
Lebensrisiken abgedeckt werden selbst
Bundestagsabgeordnete kriegen das 9
euro-ticket 300 Euro
energiepauschale die Preis Bremsen bei
Strom bei Gas ich brauche das gar nicht
und sie brauchen das wahrscheinlich auch
nicht so und und dadurch suggeriert der
Staat den Menschen das funktioniert so
wir haben eine Vollkasko Mentalität die
daraus wächst und es wird alles
übernommen und da müssen wir aufpassen
wenn wir da reingehen dann war's das mit
Deutschland dann war's das auch im
Vergleich zu anderen Ländern wenn ich
nach Südamerika Schiele Uruguay wenn ich
wenn ich mehr asiatische Länder ansehe
die sind hungrig die wollen nach vorne
und deswegen müssen wir aufpassen dass
der Wohlstand uns nicht satt gemacht hat
sondern das Eigenverantwortung in
Zukunft auch weiterhin was zählt Frau
Weber ist gleich dran und wird erstmal
sagen das ist nämlich der Vorwurf nur
weil die alten also unsere Eltern
geschuftet haben bis zum umfallen können
wir uns das heute leisten genau in
dieser frei komplett entscheiden zu
wollen Frage Nummer eins wie gehen Sie
damit um na ja die Sache ist ja auch die
also sie sagen irgendwie ne Vollkasko
Mentalität das glaube ich nicht viele
junge Menschen wenn man sich auch
Studien anschaut haben das Gefühl sie
leben von einem Gehalt zum anderen die
haben finanzielle Sorgen
Studierende warten immer noch auf ihr
Geld also weil sie das gerade
angesprochen haben ich glaube gar nicht
dass es diese Mentalität gibt sondern
eher dass man gesehen hat auch wie sich
zum Teil die Eltern oder Großeltern
Generation kaputt gearbeitet hat und in
der Rente keine schöne Rente mehr hatte
und dass junge Menschen einfach auf die
Klimakrise schauen und sagen weiß ich
auch nicht wie meine Rente aussehen wird
und dass ich die Prioritäten verschoben
werden in Zukunft die Rente die die
Menschen bekommen das Geld kommt ja
nicht vom Himmel es muss ja irgendeiner
dass er Wirtschaften was dann hinterher
verteilt wird ich meine nicht die junge
Generation Mentalität sondern sehr breit
selbst Unternehmer rufen mich neuerdings
an und sagen Sie doch mal einen Kollegen
welche Förderprogramme ist in welchem
Ministerien gibt da müssen sie halt
aufpassen das ist so ein schleichender
Prozess das wird nicht funktionieren und
deswegen ist das Null Vorwurf ich will
nur damit sagen dass wenn wir alle
weniger arbeiten werden wir weniger
Wohlstand haben diejenigen die reicher
sind sind mobiler damit der Sozialstaat
unter Druck bekommen und dann haben wir
ein Problem und das möchte ich nicht wir
könnten aber auch festlegen dass wir
weniger konsumieren dass das also ist ja
irgendwie durchaus möglich weil es gegen
uns ja sehr gut und dann gibt es als
nächstes die Diskussion darüber die groß
also finden wir es sogar erstrebenswert
nicht mehr bei den Spitzen Ländern dabei
zu sein da haben sie schon gesagt dass
sie das überhaupt nicht toll finden Frau
lang bei ihnen würde mich das jetzt aber
sehr interessieren finden Sie dass es
eine neue Diskussion darüber geben muss
was eigentlich Arbeit nicht nur Wert ist
sondern wie wichtig uns der Wohlstand
ist in diesem Land und ob er uns um
jeden Preis so viel wert ist dass
Menschen auch sich kaputt arbeiten
ich glaube das Wohlstand sehr wichtig
ist ich glaube aber auch dass dieser
Widerspruch der hier aufgemacht wird so
gar nicht wirklich funktioniert wenn wir
anschauen was braucht es denn um in
Zukunft den Wohlstand zu sichern und ich
glaube dass da eine abstrakte
wachstumsdebatte ja oder nein und gar
nicht so viel weiterbringen so müssen ja
schauen in bestimmten Bereichen werden
wir massives Wachstum brauchen Ausbau
der erneuerbaren Energien neue
Zukunftstechnologien grüne Arbeitsplätze
wie sorgen wir dafür dass die sich hier
anziehen und dafür müssen wir ja gerade
im Fachkräftemangel gegenwirken ich
finde auch schon mal kurz auf das Thema
Handwerk eingegangen als ich mein
Schulabschluss gemacht habe immer das
Mantra studieren studieren studieren das
war es nun bloß ultra und wenn man was
erreichen wollte musste man studieren
jetzt fehlen uns überall genau die
Menschen aus dem Ausbildungsberufen wenn
es darum geht wer baut eigentlich die
Wärmepumpe ein wer baut eigentlich das
Windrad auf unser glaube ich auch hier
anzusetzen in die Schulen reinzugehen in
die Berufsberatung reinzugehen dass
junge Menschen dort heute auch lernen
wenn ich ein Ausbildungsberuf macht dann
habe ich nicht nur einen sicheren Job am
Ende bin ich tatsächlich bei vielen
dieser Berufe sogar klimaschütze von
Beruf aus und so sichern wir dann auch
ein Wohlstand aber Frau lang der das
normale Gegenargument ist natürlich das
wohlstandsversprechen für diese jungen
Menschen ist ja aber nicht mehr da also
das berühmte Haus im Grünen kann sich ja
heute schon keiner mehr leisten wie soll
das erst eine zukünftige Generation mal
völlig unabhängig von der Rente also wie
lösen wir diesen Widerspruch auf dass
wir sie jetzt weiter animieren zu
arbeiten und zu schuften und sich
möglichst rumzulegen um dann aber
eigentlich in diesen persönlichen
Wohlstand gar nicht mehr zu kommen
das ist tatsächlich ein Problem also das
natürlich wenn das Mantra ist arbeitet
mehr und gleichzeitig habt ihr wenig
davon ihr könnt eure Miete trotzdem
nicht bezahlen die Vorstellung
vielleicht sogar mal ein eigenes Haus zu
haben ist weit entfernt dann ist das für
Leute ehrlich gesagt ein totale
Frustmoment und natürlich auch einer der
das Gefühl Frau Weber hat es auch ein
bisschen geschildert von dauerhafter
Krise und auch dauerhafte Unsicherheit
noch weiter verstärkt ich glaube nur auf
der einen Seite wird klimaschutzend
Zukunft der drei Wohlstand sein das
heißt hier gibt es sehr viele
Möglichkeiten auch in Zukunft Wohlstand
zu schaffen und auf der anderen Seite
ist es ein soziale Frage wie gut sind
die Löhne verdienen Frauen weiterhin 18
Prozent weniger als Männer wie
entwickelt sich die mietenpolitik also
kann ich mir vielleicht meine Wohnung
auch leisten im Zweifelsfall sogar eine
Eigentumswohnung bekommen das sind doch
dann eigentlich die Fragen auf die wir
schauen müssen also wie wird der
Wohlstand verteilt bei von mir ist so
interessant sie machen jetzt selber auch
die Erfahrung als Arbeitgeberin also am
liebsten Teilzeit Homeoffice keine
Überstunden mehr sabatical das sind ja
nicht nur Vorurteile das erleben Sie
auch als Ideen der Kollegen Kolleginnen
mit denen sie zusammenarbeiten bei der
hat die Stimme ja also tatsächlich habe
ich viele Kollegen die so und zum
millennial Generation sogenannten
gehören die irgendwie ganz selbstver
würde ich sagen obwohl sie vielleicht
gar nicht kleine Kinder haben oder sowas
das früher ein Argument gewesen wäre ich
möchte vier Tage Woche machen und
engagiere mich am fünften Tag irgendwie
ehrenamtlich oder halt ein tolles Hobby
und finde dass das für mich genau der
richtige Mix ist also auch die
Generation meiner Tochter die noch zur
Schule geht also die findet ihre Eltern
komische Workaholics sind die ist total
die ist total klug und motiviert aber
die sieht nicht ein dass man die will
intensiv arbeiten wenn sie älter ist
glaube ich aber nicht so viel wie ihre
Eltern gibt es einfach Mentalitätswandel
und wie gesagt also ich glaube das
regelt der Markt ich glaube dass die
Arbeitgeber vorne dran sein werden die
darauf eingehen die gute Angebote machen
und weil sie sagen heutige Perspektive
ich kann aber auch nur davor waren dass
du unterschätzen wie anstrengend das ist
also ich habe als Journalisten irgendwie
wirklich viele Jahre darüber geschrieben
dass das alles möglich sein soll
Vereinbarkeit Teilzeit und so weiter und
als jemand der jetzt irgendwie diese
ganzen Arbeitspläne da in Einklang
bringen muss und der eines Montag weg
und andere Nachmittag und so weiter das
ändert sich und eine eine Mitarbeiterin
die Kind bekommen hat wollte erst 50
Prozent arbeiten dann 75 dann zwei
Monate raus wegen Kita Eingewöhnung dann
wieder 50 alles mit einer Führung
zusätzliche Arbeit und sowas eigentlich
werden sie mehr Dienstleisterin für ihre
Kollegen ne das ist toll ich kann das
ich kann das gut verstehen ich glaube
auch nicht unbedingt dass die Ergebnisse
schlechter werden aber es ist halt eine
Herausforderung und ich glaube das muss
ich das muss ich in der Arbeitswelt
irgendwie rumsprechen das dass man dass
das eben auch wirklich ein auch nicht
nur aufs Gehalt ankommt sondern auf
solche Möglichkeiten auf die
Weiterbildungsmöglichkeiten die man
anbietet und so weiter und auch für
ältere übrigens also das war ich ich
finde es auch falsch immer noch auf der
Rente mit 63 rum zu reiten das ist ein
zahlenmäßig überschätztes Problem aber
die Signalwirkung die können wir uns
nicht erlauben zu sagen also Arbeitgeber
hört auf irgendwann in der bestimmten
Altersphase zu investieren als als
jemand etwas Neues angefangen bin ich
selber auch zum Beispiel also man kann
in jeder Lebensphase wirklich irgendwie
noch mal neu anfangen dazulernen
weitermachen auch das ist sowas wo wir
uns das von den Amerikanern abgucken
können das ist nicht nur ihre Generation
wir Babyboomer sind viel zu viele als
dass sich die Gesellschaft leisten
könnte bei uns auf Weiterbildung und
diese Bereitschaft was Neues anzufangen
zu verzichten also da müssen relativ
viele mitmachen das können nicht
irgendwie die viel kleinere Gruppe der
jüngeren alleine leisten und die
Gesellschaft muss ein Angebot beim Thema
Chancengerechtigkeit machen der Begriff
ist glaube ich aus der Mode gekommen so
ein bisschen alle reden eher so von
Grundeinkommen und das Ergebnis
irgendwie auszugleichen und das wäre so
ein schönes Thema auch für die Ampel die
SPD so als alte Arbeiterpartei
aufstiegspartei die FDP und ich glaube
da hat die Gesellschaft wirklich so ein
bisschen Ehrgeiz verloren also das
möglich zu machen also diesen Glauben zu
stärken dass es jeder schaffen kann ich
auch zu verbessern Frau Ricarda lang hat
es gerade schon versucht indem sie sagte
es gibt ja auch wirklich in diesem
Transformationsprozess sehr viel was in
diesem Land zu tun aber die Grünen reden
auch immer von Wände zu weniger und wir
dürfen nicht mal wach glauben und so und
das ist glaube ich der falsche Tonfall
also es gibt auch sehr viel Diskussionen
die den Optimismus dämpft und ich weiß
nicht ob uns das da weiter hilft Wände
zum weniger hättet
sie hat das Gegenteil gerade gesagt
deshalb zitierte ich sie aber jetzt ist
erstmal ein Arbeitgeber dran und ich
möchte Frau Lange natürlich gerne sofort
beim Wort nehmen wir müssen gemeinsam
für mehr Wertschätzung für berufliche
Bildung sorgen das muss die Gesellschaft
geben das muss politisch durchgesetzt
werden die Finanzierung von
Universitäten und beruflicher Bildung
sind nicht gleichwertig dort müssen
Dinge passieren die Gleichsetzung im
deutschen Qualifikationsrahmen die bitte
dort Dinge gesetzlich zu verankern und
in der zweite Punkt und auf den möchte
ich noch mal ganz wichtig eingehen wir
stehen im Wettbewerb als Handwerk wir
brauchen diese Berufe und wir können
diesen Wettbewerb mit zwei Säcken Zement
auf den Schultern nicht gewinnen die
Sozialabgaben hängen zum Großteil am
Lohn und in Zeiten von digitalen
Geschäftsmodellen und äh sechs
verschiedenen Einkunftsarten ist das
nicht mehr möglich wir können die
lohnintensiven Berufe nicht genügend
wertschätzen in der Entlohnung es ist
nicht so dass der Meister die Meisterin
nicht mehr bezahlen möchte sie können es
nicht und diese Möglichkeit muss die
Politik schaffen damit diese Berufe eine
Chance haben im Wettbewerb das muss man
jetzt noch mal ganz kurz erklären sie
sagen ihre Handwerker können sich den
eigenen Handwerker nicht leisten weil
sie die Stunde so teuer abrechnen müssen
und in Rechnung stellen müssen weil
zusätzlich zum Leistungslohn eben dann
noch lauter Abgaben dazu kommen nur noch
mal zu erklären das was der die
Fachkraft netto bekommt und das was der
Betrieb brutto mit Umsatzsteuer in
Rechnung stellen muss ist soweit
auseinander gerutscht dass sie sich ein
normaler Mensch der ein normales
Einkommen selbst nicht mehr leisten kann
der der die Leistung erbringt kann sie
sich selbst nicht kaufen
was ist denn knapp auf dieser Welt
Rohstoffe Gas und was ist das teuerste
Arbeit das ist falsch dort müssen wir
ran okay
ihre Antwort auf Herrn Dittrich
ich verstehe einmal das grundsätzliche
Problem was wir in Deutschland
tatsächlich eine Situation haben wo
Arbeit relativ hoch besteuert wird im
Vergleich zum Beispiel zu vermögen da
stehen wir relativ schlecht da im
internationalen Vergleich gleichzeitig
müssen wir natürlich sehen wenn wir
jetzt an die Lohnnebenkosten rangehen
dann würde es am Ende nichts anderes
bedeuten als Leistungskürzung bei der
Krankenversicherung bei der
Rentenversicherung ich glaube in dem
Kontext dass wir gerade besprochen haben
das wäre ein weniger an sozialer
Sicherheit für sehr viele Menschen das
kann auch nicht der Weg sein
komplett anders ich glaube dass die
Sozialversicherungsbeiträge gerade die
kleineren Einkommen auffressen werden
dass die sich nicht nur mehr ein ein
Handwerker nicht mehr leisten können
sondern dazu selbst arbeiten gehen und
aufgefressen werden von den hohen
Sozialversicherungsbeiträgen allein im
krankenkassenbereich durch den
medizinischen Fortschritt und durch die
Babyboomer worüber wir in dieser Sendung
reden gehen die Beiträge in die Höhe
deswegen hat er Dietrich recht wir
checken das in unserer
grundsatzkommission wir machen gerade
ein neues Programm ich bin dafür erstmal
zu überprüfen ob es nicht Sinn macht
mindestens ein Teil über Steuern zu
finanzieren und das ganze System mal
aufzubrechen so wie es im Moment
funktioniert hat es keine Zukunft
also ich tut mir leid also an der Stelle
muss ich jetzt mal kurz daran erinnern
für ganz viele Menschen die wichtigste
Person um in Arbeit zu vermitteln was
wir hier gerade diskutieren heißt im
Grunde genommen Löhne hoch oder
Sozialversicherungssysteme runter damit
die Menschen weiter mit Freude in ihren
Arbeitsplätzen bleiben und wir eben
nicht ein Land werden dass sich im
Abschwung befindet so also
die Frage ist tatsächlich wie motivieren
wir beide Seiten die Arbeitgeber und die
Arbeitnehmer Lohnforderungen von 15 %
liegen dann auf dem Tisch bei der Post
wenn wir vermeiden wollen dass die Post
ihre zustellungspflicht einstellt so
also wir hätten ja dann wirklich zu
moderieren dass ich Firmen verabschieden
aus ihren wichtigen Funktionen in diesem
Land es ist eine ratlose Frage an sie
würden sie es auflösen Sie also ich
glaube Politikerin also ich glaube man
muss sich wirklich verabreden wir haben
dafür ein gutes Modell das die
tarifpartnerschaft die im gesamten ganz
guten Aushandlungsprozess hinbekommt und
selten mal wirklich solche Forderungen
15 stimmt dann am Ende auch tatsächlich
Realität werden und zum zweiten glaube
ich tatsächlich dass wir erkennen müssen
dass wir durch also wir haben heute
Abend überhaupt nicht über einen anderen
Demografie muss auch
Automatisierung küssen manches von denen
werden vielleicht am Ende tatsächlich
wegen der hohen Personalkosten Menschen
nicht mehr machen der Mix wird auch an
anderer werden wir zum Beispiel als
Bundesagentur werden in den nächsten
zehn Jahren 35.000 Beschäftigte
verlieren die kriegen wir wahrscheinlich
auf dem Markt gar nicht mehr rekrutiert
also habe ich eine Karte der
Automatisierung ausgerufen nicht weil
wir Personal einsparen wollen sondern
weil unsere Leistung mit weniger
Personal erbringen müssen und ich glaube
wenn wir diesen Faktor noch dazu
kann man auch gucken wieder weder Mix
nachher von Abgang scheuen und dem was
wir an Personal für bestimmte
Tätigkeiten brauchen auch noch mal neu
ausgehandelt werden kann also von daher
bin ich immer noch optimistisch das ist
uns mit mit allen Beteiligten gelingen
kann das Problem auch am Ende
auszuhandeln das müssen wir nämlich
aushandeln weil es eine
verteilungspolitische Frage am Ende
sowohl was Ressourcen als auch was Geld
als auch was Abgaben und Steuern angeht
ist